Michelle Carter was sentenced to 15
months in a Massachusetts jail for
involuntary manslaughter Carter had sent
Conrad Roy dozens of text messages
encouraging him to take his own life go
ahead and do it why haven't you done it
yet you haven't done it well get back in
your truck and try again to kill
yourself this is a groundbreaking case
because we don't see levels of evil like
this in the world like it doesn't happen
he killed himself by carbon monoxide
inhalation after Carter sent him
numerous text messages urging him to
commit suicide she sat on the phone with
him as he died she heard his last breath
apparently you're just making it harder
on yourself or pushing it off you have
to do it do you want to do it now like
I'm reading these things and I'm like
he's dead she was talking about brushing
his teeth
the term wolf in sheep's clothing is
thrown around this is a wolf in sheep's
clothing this girl might look innocent
might look pretty like you talk about
the devil she is the [__] devil is
she then responsible that is such a
young age for being a young woman who's
clearly going through difficult things
herself we're not dealing with a nutter
here a nutter and a sick evil [__] are
not the same thing the reason that they
had to work out whether or not this was
a crime is because people aren't this
[__] evil and in that courtroom the
only time she cried was when they were
sentencing her all of the pain all of
the messages all of the agony that she'd
caused no flicker of emotion just
deadpan cold [__]
[Music]
mmm this week on the true jaudy podcast
podcast we'll be watching a program on
sky crime y'know we really should be
getting a [__] faithfulness yeah I'm
sky you know at some point we got a it's
it's a program called
I love you now die and it's the story of
a girlfriend who depending on which side
of the fence you sit on instructed her
boyfriend to commit suicide
yeah and he did so and then there was
his massive core case where basically
it's like is she to blame because he was
clearly suicidal but mentally ill but by
the letter of the law is telling someone
to commit suicide and then them doing it
does that make you guilty of
manslaughter or not and that's what this
whole thing is about because part of it
is like if you tell someone to jump off
a bridge and they do it is that your
fault how responsible I for someone
else's actions and yeah and how
influential are you on someone else's
mind body and soul well yeah and I mean
I'm very influential and I for one once
you ought to live now for the record
although you know if you do die your
YouTube accounts still subscribed so you
lost nothing then yes yeah anyway what I
would say is I got some admit a little
more before we start this since Brian
released the mental health video alright
Brian and I both received a lot of
messages from people who have said thank
you or I don't want to make it sound
like we're digging ourselves out what I
mean is like people did you get messages
that's a no it's a messages was my video
yeah I reviewed it no I did send it to
you and I was like what do you think and
you were like cuz when you speak about
mental health it is such a sensitive
topic you want you may them tell you
absolutely is this good enough yeah and
you actually said put it on the main
channel it's important people say this I
was like alright
yeah I had already uploaded a TG 2 then
yeah because the video quality was [__]
and I was like people want well when you
used to such high quality most of the
youtubers looked at that and went [__]
you know did he film this on a red
so a lot of people message and said
there have been times I've been feeling
really low and I'm not saying that we
stopped people from you know doing
something awful but what we did maybe do
is give someone some company when they
needed it and we've kind of just put
podcasts out there and put everything
we've done out there maybe if it makes
if it brings laughter into people's eyes
so be it that's what we want to do but
what I don't want to do is cause this to
be then something that triggers someone
or make someone feel bad in a way so
just know we are going to be discussing
suicide during this and a lot of quite
dark things so we're not going to be
insensitive I'll put it that way no but
you know people know our sense of humor
at this point the jokes will be made he
has a caveat however I mean out of all
the big UK youtubers I think I'm the one
who's discussed suicide in in a
passionate way the most I would say is
completely this is a topic close to home
it's something I care about I don't want
anyone to ever take their own life
that's the message behind that video
that I made is keep going
happiness will come and that is the
message that this girl should have been
telling her boyfriend now that is then
this is the crux of the whole situation
if we timeline it just a little bit
these two met very briefly when
introduced by parents or it can be give
a bit of a description of these two yeah
because if you haven't seen it yet it is
a little bit quite an innocent little
relationship that is all too common in
today's society where people they spend
most of their time texting rather than
actually seeing each other thousands of
1000 text messages how many did you have
a relationship like that when you were
in your teens yeah it was a bit like
that yeah because I've gone when you're
living with your parents it sometimes
you know you can't get away and
especially if you have a car or you know
you live in a small town there's not
necessarily a way to get to someone
who's five miles and also like the thing
that keeps being repeated as these are
two very lonely kids but like also when
you're in your teens 17 18 19 who isn't
lonely at that age like you do you feel
like a lost spirit who doesn't know who
they are yet because you are like most
people don't know who they are yet by
the age but what they don't I
the thing that makes people feel
extremely losses they don't know that
that period of their life will then
change into a period where you've gone
through the self-reflection in your
teens and then you begin to become an
adult look if you think that will last
forever yeah and also you know you're
listening to certain kinds of music
you're feeling lonely you're feeling
like alright no one no understands me
and all those feelings seem very
original and very unique to you because
then the first time you've ever thought
it and they actually classic and we all
feel them when we're getting to that age
and you've got this girl who's quite a
pretty girl but in a hmm what did you
describe her as like get all pretty sort
of thing that wasn't my exact wording
but I said she definitely looked less
well-off yeah I called the girl next
door yeah that was a funny thing was I
said she looks like the girl that comes
from a quite I don't mean this in a
disparaging way quite a poor part of
town and Brian's like yeah the girl next
door to me yes and he is kind of like a
little bit nerdy on some pictures he
looks very skinny yeah it's got like
sort of very teenage skin where is it
sometimes you watch footage or see
photos he's got a lot of spots and
handsome lad yeah but I looked at him
and I thought you look like you need a
good meal in you in a few Jim sessions
like quite a sort of scrawny kid but
yeah and that happens to some teams
especially is when you look at his
parents his dad's not particularly well
built as granddad was a very big guy I
wonder if that was something else that
would happen there yeah and none other
family are particularly athletic
athletic yeah so he clearly came from a
background where he wasn't that a fluid
guy you don't see her speak much but at
one point you do see him talking to like
a youtube video and you think oh this is
a very articulate quite a smart
individual yeah and unfortunately like
people who are contemplating their
existence and who suffer from depression
they usually the smart people who are
like wondering why am I here what is my
purpose am i doing this enough am I good
people who spend that much time thinking
they're usually the smart ones and it's
almost a torturous quality to hell yeah
which is difficult because especially
when you're a teen and if you do if you
don't have adults around you who are
willing to engage in that kind of
conversation people can be quite
dismissive of that because when you
can't get to the stage where we are in
our lives where we've we're not by any
means we found an answer but people can
be quite dismissive ago called you over
thinking it or blah blah blah especially
if our parents who are quite normal
people going through their own divorce
having there are no other rooms
maybe not abusive but definitely there
was violence in that household yeah he
got beaten up by his dad it seemed they
had a fight I don't know how bad it was
or how regular it was like his dad
clearly loved his son but they yeah they
had the kind of relationship where that
would happen occasionally you do get the
feeling that there was a confrontation a
lot and that this guy was he wasn't
being listened to
yeah as a sudden he his parents when you
see them reflecting on their
relationship with this son they were not
aware fully of just how dark it was in
his mind and so these two were very much
in a relationship where where it felt
like them against the world they were
framing things in a very not to be
disrespectful classic teenage way we're
Romeo and Juliet with this with that the
devil is our leader those kind of things
coming up with some dark [__] but I
think I don't know if both sides of it
were that way I feel after reading the
text messages like he fully was invested
in this as a as a pain relationship
where they're both suffering together in
this world me on Julia whereas for her
she was writing her own movie that
wasn't Romeo and Juliet she was writing
a movie where she survives him and goes
on and it's almost like Kate Winslet in
Titanic and lives the rest of her life I
would everyone off yeah yeah she's the
one who carries but for him it was very
much almost like we're both gonna end it
well the Maria and Juliet he texts her
in it she goes you know how that ends
and she's like oh no I wouldn't want
that and you're like oh right okay we
just want him to die then we're racing I
had a little book I think so some of the
some of the notes I've made here
basically I think when she realized he
was ill
it felt like through the text messages
she sort of seen an opportunity there to
create her own reality using him as a as
a I find that when you deal with nutters
and I don't mean people who don't
understand right from wrong as like
people who run out in front of cars and
things like that I think when you deal
with you know how women get this sort of
bunny-boiler label I think not just
women but men as well you you get
self-obsessed people who feel like
they're living a movie and they are the
star of the show and I feel like when I
read her messages I thought I can see
what you're doing here you're you feel
like he's an extra in the life story
that is your movie whereas he thinks
that you and him or that Heather at
Bonnie and Clyde yeah yeah actor and
actress the leading roles whereas he is
just an accessory in your life how and
that's what I wonder is how conscious of
that construction she was or whether
because she was just looking I'm
reaching out for whatever she could to
make some meaning in her life that this
was the first thing that she found she
watched Glee that there was the whole
story around the actress in Glee who had
the boyfriend who overdosed so this was
for those who don't know that Glee was a
teen sure where they used to sing and
all of that [__] and so popular it was
it was huge and basically that the two
leading characters once again were in a
relationship on the shore but also in
real life genius he died in real life
they had to write him out of the show
and everyone felt very sorry and crowded
around and Lea Michele I think anymore
became almost the hero of it because she
was given lot of air time she was on
Ellen she was oh no she was everywhere
it was like he was the best man and you
know he was amazing he made me feel
incredible I don't know if I'll ever
find this again I'm well the cliche and
what you realize that I even wrote down
one of the core to myself where Lea
Michele in in Glee says you are my first
and I want you to be my last yeah what
you find is she is using exact quotes
from
Lea Michele the character she plays and
the real person in interviews towards
him and then after his death as well so
you can see just how much of a movie she
feels like this all is I'll also say
this he clearly didn't watch Glee right
so when he receives that text message or
he'll take that as oh my god this girl
is a [__] poet like this woman is
coming up with stuff that really makes
her think she like it touches him Dupin
is hot I'd imagine so and I don't Majan
even if you got that as another teenage
girl you might not draw the line between
it being ingly or you love watch playing
on God she feels the same that's so
lovely he seemed a bit of a able to a
lads like quite oh he was definitely a
man's man so there's one story that
definitely made me feel like he was part
of that which was when he got his
captain's license from the boat and it
was a really proud moment for his
grandfather and obviously for the family
that he'd gone out there and done this
and that he was doing something with his
life and he was achieving he was clearly
very intelligent because he got a
captain's license for a boat and that
was weeks before he died yeah which I
find was one of the things made me
really question the whole thing because
I thought if you're so depressed that
you want to realistically want to kill
yourself in a way where your life is so
often you get the motivation to get up
out of bed and get your cut-ins license
on a boat do you really have that that
level of motivation or do you not
understanding well as someone who's
known people who you know have committed
suicide there's there's obviously high
functioning people who can get on with
things for the sake of loved ones but to
do that is very strange because it is a
self-motivated self beneficial act it's
not you're not doing it this you know
I'm got like people that look after and
stuff like that it's strange so to me
while this was clearly a troubled young
man who was on Prozac had tried to
overdose before but I don't there's
people who take tablets that I think is
a cry for help sometimes rather than a
serious attempt the severity of it I'm
not trying to say I don't take it
seriously
oh I don't think it's
there is clearly levels in attempting
suicide where you think if someone pulls
a shotgun on themselves it's different
than when you take an overdose of pain
pills and the fact that he did that it's
sure that there was issues but I don't
know and the real question of this is
would he have done it without the
influence of her and that's the key
that's what it were heads to and it's
very much like a catfish on my scenario
these two people meet a maximum of like
five times I think in the whole relation
and what that allows you to do is
construct an identity which isn't really
true to life so she's saying I love you
it's very easy to say I love you to
someone that you barely ever see that
you can control what they see of you you
can give this image of you off as to
whatever you want and also if you're
gonna like it's [__] yeah but as a
teenager that kind of very real very
real not patronize teenage knows what
you've got I remember that feeling when
you haven't got anyone else who was
giving you that attention saying those
words appear on the screen and that is
it the emotions are going off in your
brain yeah you're obviously getting a
chemical reaction there that probably
gives to him a man suffering from
depression a young young man a little
bit of a booster like yeah yeah and but
but then when she uses that to take him
further down the dark road he says he's
hearing voices in his head saying to
kill himself but I don't know it's the
devil by the way yeah that there's
things he says where I think I wonder
how real he is being that's exactly what
I thought when I read it I thought wow I
remember because I remember there were
people I slipped not in my school and
like all those kind thing they would say
dark [__] all the time and I'd be like
yeah for effect for effect because it
was like that's a cool thing to say it's
cool that the devil is like speaking to
me or whatever and you're like yeah yeah
because people who I remember in my high
school were the most you know middle
class wholesome family troubled like
never had a problem in their life type
people no not a not a deep not a problem
at the level that other people here's
what I'm saying people want to see
meaning from life sometimes only in
their look in places like I'll become a
goth for example where they want to
stand out they want to look like a
troubled soul they want to they want to
be in pain for the sake of it and I'm
not saying that that happened with this
kid by any means but sometimes you just
say people saying things and doing
things just for how it sounds or how it
looks how unhealthy do you think is in
society in general that when we talk
about suicide we can't really have an
honest evaluation of why and how that
person died because we don't want to
upset a family or we don't want to upset
the people around them and if we're
being honest and we're really trying to
get to the bottom of a scenario
sometimes you have to say something
that could sound cruel in order to
really be kind to those people and let
them actually process what what we're
dealing with here it's kind of like a
murder because someone's murdered
themselves essentially yeah and when
you're doing an examination of what went
wrong you know say for example you're
judging a murder and you're a detective
you can't be worrying about people's
feelings you need to get to the root of
what went wrong here and I think all too
often was suicide
people go oh well you just depressed
like and they don't look into it enough
and there isn't because ultimately often
with suicide the people who died or the
were failed by those around them and
that's and that is the sad truth that we
don't want to say because it is going to
be upsetting to some people and I'm not
saying all the time because sometimes
there are some people who are so gone
and so troubled that it is almost beyond
health but that's much rarer than I
think we we make out
we all think what if we could have just
had a conversation with this person I
could have done and that's true like
there there is help there is there is
there is things that you can do to help
people that's why we're always
encouraging people to talk and like I
said in my video
it's not just on them nor it's on the
people around them that when you spot
that you got you got to reach out and
grab them literally and say no you know
what I mean and sometimes that doesn't
happen and you know what it is if you if
there is someone who commits suicide and
you didn't reach out grab them before it
happened I'm not saying beat yourself up
and feel bad but but there's a
difference between that and then being
very very nasty to someone before that
happens so it's nothing what we're
looking at here so do you think and I
guess that's likely that happens more or
say this than what people would like to
admit
so I suppose me I bet you those final
conversations that have happened that no
one's ever admitted too many times oh
yeah in circumstances of suicide this is
one thing I also thought was in many
ways she was the one who was left behind
to clean up the mess that they both made
between them in a way and that's what I
found very almost unfair on her was that
whilst he was the one who had killed
himself she was left behind to answer
for everyone else as nessam I think
that's what she wanted partly yeah and I
think she in her mind she it should she
planned it like that actually there
right there yeah because she did the
charity event after we're racing yeah I
had a bit but like there was so we
haven't gone into the messages yet and
we will get to the specifics of how bad
it was the things that she said to him
but you talk one thing she did so I
think was a me a few days before he
actually finally went through with him
he wasn't missing at all she's texting
him we've got the record you can see
them for yourself in the in the actual
documentary but she starts telling it
her friends people that she knows
they're not really her friends did often
don't give a [__] about about the looks
of it but he's missing oh my god
where is he what's gonna happen he said
this he said and what she's trying to do
is gauge what it's gonna be like when he
finally goes through with it and she's
planning and she's also wanting to feel
is it gonna be worth that I think it
feels that way she's up because she is
wondering what level of attention am I
gonna get if this actually all comes off
so I was a taste of that so I did wonder
Oh
see we don't if he'd have attempted and
then he hadn't have died maybe we'd just
have been going okay these were two
people who were sort of playing chicken
with each other in a way or kind of I
just wonder whether she just wanted the
attention of saying anything like that
so a lot of people are treated that is a
trial run I think she just wanted the
attention anyway I think that's I think
it's boss I think Ryan's both young I
think for her this kid meant nothing to
her do you really after after reading
the messages I think she seen him coming
a mile off and thought you I can work
with this like right so she's very
lonely herself she's got an eating
disorder she's had some mental health
issues but she's certainly not a psycho
who doesn't know right from wrong she is
a smart girl clearly intelligent and she
I think when he walked in her life she
thought he has someone who's desperate
like I'm desperate the difference is he
was desperate for something different
she was desperate for attention he was
desperate for someone to help him to
give meaning I think what where he was
coming to reach out for that she was
like oh no like I can use this to my
advantage to make more people care about
me then look I want to build my numbers
up so you know him the only way that I
disagree or would question what you said
there is and I've sought interested in
the psychologist in the show where he
was going through and basically trying
to insinuate that it wasn't a nasty or
malicious area that she came from but it
was that this was someone who was so
desperate and so troubled that they
didn't know she didn't know and it
almost flipped through the conversation
where where she thought in the end if
she was she thought she was helping him
so I would I would take them on that and
I would say that's absolute bollocks
what do you have to say how can you
prove the other way where am I yes the
thing is right from wrong mm-hmm at its
most basic level when a human being is
threatening to commit suicide you reach
out and you stop them mm-hmm in the fact
that she did the opposite and encouraged
it there's no
what he's doing is creating a false
reality where she's helping him like the
times where he thought about not
committing suicide she actually said no
no you gotta do that it's like she
insisted he do that so that
psychologists breakdown it was clear I
was on the payroll from the defense and
it was just like God you will say
anything only because anyone and this
isn't you don't have to have a
psychology degree and no common sense
tells you if you encourage someone to
commit suicide you are you are an
absolute piece of [__] if you're so I'm
I'm not necessarily what he's
insinuating is what he's insinuating is
what it became about for her is getting
attention and it wasn't about being evil
while I'm sorry the facts are that when
you care about a bit of attention over
the life of another human being you are
evil you are pure evil what about when
you're then having conversations in text
messages where you're talking about the
devil and the devil if the devil becomes
like the framing of the whole thing
where the devil encourages people to do
wrong he encourages people to maybe to
commit suicide maybe steal awful things
in their life what if that flips it
comes remember my messages right right
not everything you message you're
actually gonna do you actually really
mean yeah this is fun to see talk and I
think with this for them it was almost
like fun it was fun to see it was a
level of sexual tension was
romanticizing this thing that they were
doing and making it feel all-father
so then what about the less romantic
side where he says if you dare tell
anyone and there'll be repercussions
because there were toes i would only
hear you I would hold on I would only
hate you because that is a very
manipulative thing and I'm not saying
therefore he bears all the
responsibility but it is a very
manipulative thing to say so because why
would you care about that if you if you
actually wanted to die what if you
really wanted to die why would you care
about people finding out the things that
you were saying in my opinion he never
really fully planned on going through
with this
so you're saying why do you care about
it right because his mom didn't know and
he would lie to her
and say ah my mom see in the computer
and she didn't bat an eyelid might
because he had this how to commit
suicide on that yeah and she didn't care
what he wanted to to portray to the girl
Michelle was that his mother didn't care
about Lamar and his mother had no idea
it was this bad so he was that that
proves this was fantasy so then portly
and how much of this then is teenagers
constructing their own reality between
them where the mum for instance is
clearly having a hard time ourselves
she's going through a divorce I think
she was on antidepressants some
antidepressants are very strong to the
point where people can take information
and not react to it
and I do wonder how much of this is a
mother who isn't necessarily not caring
for a son but a mother who doesn't can't
care for her son because she's in her
own world of pain usually not the mother
seemed that what I'm saying is the
mother do not like the mother my mother
denies it but then you know how do we
know the mother doesn't have her own
issues at heart she did strike me as
Anna's very judgmental she struck me
someone with their own problems I agree
problems but the one thing that
convinced me that the mother was a
decent human being was after everything
that little girl did to her son the
mother said I almost can't even hate her
because she's clearly so sick in the
head I think like and and I thought for
you to speak like that to almost forgive
I'm not saying she forgave her but to
come to terms with what has happened the
level of pain you you can only do that
if you've got love inside of you and
you've got care and you've got
compassion and that kind of compassion
that you can sure for this girl who's
destroyed your son and you can look at
that girl and go I can't even I can't
even demonize you because you're clearly
so ill that you would do that or my boy
mm-hmm like that is a that is realistic
fair player thought of the mother for
saying that can i play devil's advocate
sure because i don't mean this in a mean
way it's much easier to forgive someone
if in court you have almost been
vindicated by that woman by the door by
the by michelle because
she's almost taken the fall and I don't
meet and I say that not meaning to blame
the mother
not at all but you get what I'm saying
when I say that this is the thing is the
pain that that mother will live with for
the rest of her life and that and the
father means she hasn't taken the fall
the mother and father I've taken the
fall after that little [__] is going to
get out of court get out of jail and
gone with the rest of her life and and
meet someone and maybe have a happy
ending there's no happy ending for that
mother and for me I've said so the truth
is they have taken the fall and the fire
Archie is able to still show compassion
towards that girl in say an almost piteå
for the for them for the sickness that
she's actually short I don't know that
convinced me I thought because I you
we've we've seen we've seen other famous
parents on TV not sure that level of
compassion and and I don't blame them
when someone's done somebody a kid I
just I don't know it convinced me that
this was someone who was telling the
truth that was that's really interesting
cuz I I'm not sure I read it exactly
that way but maybe that's
inconsequential anyway there was a point
in the documentary where they do talk
about there are two families here who
are banking on it this court case almost
vindicating them of responsibility I did
think that was a very good point
because as parents imagine going through
that where it's like your child has
either helped in the suicide or your
child is a manipulative young man who
has committed suicide and taken this
girl along for a ride with him and
neither are true exactly in in reality
but they're banking on this you know and
when both families walk away I feel like
the mother and father of the boy have to
sit there and go we should have seen
this yeah and the mother and father of
the girl also have to say we should have
seen this from her because of the
messages that the girl sent God imagine
knowing you raised a [__] monster
like that some who wins now because this
is the thing is what what is suicidal
thoughts
it is literally your brain telling it's
we this I need ahead my life and what
you need and many people have them but
what gets them through it is the hard
times passing the good times coming some
more from the family support from the
front even I've had suicidal thoughts
and it did make me think like I wonder
if someone I loved or really thought was
great was telling me every [__] day
at Nana
you're better off killing yourself like
[__] hell it's bad enough when the
brains telling itself that let alone
outside influence saying that as well I
mean it's gonna be the worst possible
thing it just affirms what you're
thinking really because what you do is
you vocalize something to work out if
you're right or wrong but in the other
person goes no yes and then you go oh
I'm right or I'm wrong but just to put
it into perspective and we'll read some
of the messages up it wasn't even like
she was going I think you should commit
suicide you know it was it was a lot
more like aggressive he doing like it
seemed like on the hour every hour
towards the end like when are you going
to do it are you doing it tonight are
you gonna do it tomorrow what time we
need all right make sure you do it
thought why haven't you doing it you
know you'll not do it if you don't wait
until you know like she was like you
could see her excitement like this was
about to happen how much she think that
she didn't think he'd go through it
the only the only thing that I think is
so every night he would go to bed there
were some nights we go to bed and you go
I will kill myself tonight and then she
be messaging wake up the next day and
he'd still be there and to some extent
there's a bit of a thrill that she feels
like she's the girl who loves a guy
who's so there is that every girl not
every girl a lot of women are a lot of
people in relationships want someone
they can save someone who is a tortured
soul a wild person someone who's
tortured by the devil or something that
they don't an energy they don't know and
this person can help save that person
some I didn't love that the knight in
shining armor thing is something I get
put on men but it's generally women as
well it goes both ways there's a
princess who says yeah we're people love
saving someone and feeling like I can
help them not just something that
relationships have been started on for
hundreds of years even well yeah because
that's a very natural dynamic
I don't know I I personally don't think
it was about saving him I think that was
a lie from the defense to try and make
her come across as or she just thought
she was helping him and did this defense
she thought she was helping him just to
be clear that the lawyers she thought
she was helping him he has a message
drink bleach hang yourself jump off a
building stab yourself I don't know
there's lots of ways to do it
helping him the fact that a lawyer like
I understand that lawyers have got to do
what they have to do but [__] me to get
up in court and to speak on behalf of
that little [__] monster like that do
you ever wonder if that's actually a
good way of getting like it should the
lawyer actually do that like is that
really in the best interest of even her
because if you think of it this for I
know in the court system it's basically
we either get you off or you go to
prison realistically in the long run
what she actually needs is to
rehabilitate she should have done from
the get-go its pled guilty yeah so to be
told by a lawyer don't worry we'll get
you off this because you aren't actually
responsible for this this isn't really
you blah blah blah is that helping her
what she should have been told by her
lawyers he's doing a horrible thing
right the kid had problems clearly but
you admit you've made him ten times
worse and getting to the eventual how he
died like she clearly had a massive
impact on the final day as well she
should have been told that and lawyers
should be more responsible but it isn't
about that it's about winning case it's
a reasonable no this is the mad thing
about being a lawyer is probably a lot
of them get into it to bring justice to
the world but then what are what are the
the best-known lawyers in the world
known for getting off the ones who
clearly did it you're talking about
[__] OJ Simpson's lawyer Michael
Jackson's lawyer the ones who when it's
like clearly he [__] did it
and you get them off it's like what a
lawyer generally I mean Kardashian and
all that you so someone get one question
for you someone suggested in the core
why didn't he blocker than if he was
that bad why didn't he blocker what did
you think when they said that it was an
interesting defense it was because love
doesn't work that way because strong
emotions don't work that way because
guilt doesn't really work that way
because maybe he did block her at some
point and then unblocked her because we
don't know that the exact thought
processes and I did think one thing that
was dangerous about this whole court
case was we were almost taking the text
messages as if they were the only thing
that matter in this and then inferring
feelings from that on both sides and the
adults were very quick to rush to kids
nowadays they live in the digital space
and I was a bit like yeah but to me
though it was deeper on both sides I
still think she's responsible I still
think she was guilty but I also think
saying just block someone is such a 40
year old man or woman thing to do and go
well why didn't they block them then
you're like her defense yeah it was
thought your old man yeah but you get
what I mean it's like if you've had to
go through blocking someone or if you've
blocked someone for a real reason then
you know even how difficult that is or
how weird that can feel well guilty in
this day and age how easy it is to get
Road though yeah and yeah and how even
if she blocks you can get round all
sorts email email calls you can block
your number all those kind of things
right okay so here are some of the
messages he said okay I'm gonna do it to
do do you promise she says I promise
babe I have to like right now crush him
up this is about suicide it where do I
go
question Mach sad face so he's looking
at her for instructions literally tell
me what to do what do you think he did
the emoji of a sad face thing why do you
he is like where do I go sad face like I
don't know what to do like that's what
the way I'm reading that from an emotion
from the emoji right and you can't break
a promise and just go in a quiet part in
a lot of something do it like that then
he goes I'm in the worst pain right now
it's unbearable she says I think it's
time to do it now then do you agree
Conrad answer me let me write so what
else did they say can I shall see what
do you think when he's talking about the
pain what pain do you think he's talking
about there I feel mental pain it seems
but what kind of what do you imagine
when you hear him say that because he's
obviously not talking about physical
pain he's clearly in he's clear
physically he's fine maybe he's in a
very dark depression yeah which is you'd
be sleep-deprived
he being when you're depressed you you a
lot of people go all you sleep alert
when you're depressed
actually the reason a lot of people try
and sleep when they're depressed is
because they sleep so badly they can't
get to that level of sleep with it
really bothers yeah some of the other
things last night was it you keep
pushing it off and you say all do it but
you never do it's always gonna be like
that way unless you take action you're
just making it harder on yourself or
pushing it off you have to do it do you
want to do it now like I'm reading these
things and I'm like you think she was
talk about brushing his teeth mmm this
is insane
how much do you think she didn't know
that the phone if he does die because
very often when you're in the middle of
it you don't think of all the
ramifications you just think of your own
benefit how much do you think she didn't
think that those messages would ever be
seen that wasn't wrestling I just
thought how did you do not think this
through / when when even when the police
came to her she was very relaxed and
she'd I don't think she was aware that
she was in any danger at all so now I
think she was really interested in
naivety at the age she was 18 or
whatever the fact that they were like
well did you speak to her and she was
like yeah I mean I think he mentioned it
yeah and it's like dude you had a
45-minute conversation where he stepped
out of a car which had carbon monoxide
going onto it so to get to that point so
basic that there's a lot of messages can
I just say this I one of my one of the
first things I did at university was I
did a journalism
course and we had to go to court for the
day uh-huh one thing I worked out from
that was how
many people don't know how much evidence
a mobile phone can give in a court case
they basically nailed the guy in this
court case because you can triangulate
exactly where someone's position is
based on a ping uh this guy who's
clearly sitting in the dock had no
[__] idea that this information was
coming his way
and I remember sick all of us none of us
had any idea because we were new
journalists now journalism teacher who
covered court cases before was like wait
for it she knew it was coming and we and
then when they did this it was basically
banging him to rights it's like well
this shows that you took this bus this
shows that you did this this shows that
you whirring is this exact location I
think the most people think when the
person dies almost like the phone dies
with them yeah well we're never getting
that open he'd left suicide notes with
all the you can open all my accounts
like this he'd clearly left the code for
his phone or those kind of things so I
think she thought I will never these
will never be read I people don't know
this etc etc well one of the final
messages she said is your overturning
they'll see the generator and realize
you breathed in say your he goes so
should I keep it in the back seat or the
front she goes in the front you could
write it on a piece of paper on tape
saying carbon monoxide or something if
you're scared but basically miss Hara
moon he's finally in a car park he's
went and got a generator she's basically
directing him and what to do and he
started breathing in carbon monoxide and
he gets scared he's in pain he's
actually physically in pain now
he's actually realizing like this is
gonna happen I'm beginning to new
consciousness he gets out the car he
then has a phone call with her that
tracked on record to last 45 minutes 47
million now we don't know what was said
in that but she confessed that a later
date or one of her friends that he got
out of the car he rung me as he was
committing suicide and he said he didn't
want to do it he was getting scared and
I said him get the [__] back in the car
and get on with it
know when you look at all of her
previous messages in the way she's
desperate for him to do this the fact
that the core log is perfectly in line
with everything that she said in that
confession and the fact that he then
dark
you would let you would believe that
this is true yeah now we can dissect
that but one of the things the defense
said is well she also said a lot of
things that weren't true
for example she had a lesbian
relationship that another person denied
so therefore what's true what isn't true
are you gonna believe everything that is
in the messages and I thought myself as
a defense that is sloppy we're talking
about a relationship she said she had
with a girl that other girl Dena yeah
all right that's not dead and all she
lied at one time then we're talking
about a series of events that line up
perfectly with a confession where he
actually ends up dead and you're
comparing those two things I just
thought that the defense was so weak it
was no wonder that the the verdict came
in guilty be a partly wondering whether
he just did the best with what she was
giving him it was sort of like well the
best we can get her as reasonable doubt
because there's no way of exactly no but
that's just the one thing that really
like to my knowledge anyway the way it
came across is that she sat on the phone
with him as he died mm-hmm she heard his
last breath apparently called
[__] like cold like this is the reason
this way I wanted to even talk about
this is like this is the kind of like
evil dark like manipulative cow that you
you hope pray you never meet in your
life especially because she comes in the
form that the term wolf in sheep's
clothing is thrown around this is a wolf
in sheep's clothing this girl might look
innocent might look pretty but she is
the dead like you talk about the devil
she is the [__] devil his dog there
was a point in the documentary where
they sort of reference this because I
bought into it so quickly you know like
this there's a very common image now in
America in England a lot of Western
civilization
a teenage girl can be as evil vindictive
nasty person how much do you worry that
you're just doing
confirmation bias where it's like yep I
thought she was that she's that I'm not
at all
you don't worry about know if anything
I told I don't think that teenage girls
like evil vindictive people at all I
think that was a [__] defense like
all you just blaming her because she's a
young woman it's like what are you
talking about like
I think just the fact that you would
even go there and say oh this is a
generalization sorry have you [__]
looked at the evidence mate look this is
a groundbreaking case because we don't
see levels of evil like this in the
world like it doesn't happen this is the
reason that they would work out whether
or not this was a crime is because
people aren't this [__] evil like the
way she did it in such a clever way to
where that it might not be on her
because the the debate they put across
is well if someone tells you to rob a
bank and you rob a bank is it their
fault and it's like well no but if you
instruct someone to go murder someone
and they do that you are actually partly
responsible as well well there's also
the the whole drinking the kool-aid all
those kind of things but there's it
shows also instructor if you if you
basically pay someone to go murder
someone or whatever and instruct them he
literally will get banged or bullets if
he tells someone's gonna rob a bank you
will also go to prison but man and what
this was was almost like that it was
like she I think she conned him into
thinking she loved him yeah and he was
in this sort of Romeo and Juliet shape
when she literally was I I want this guy
died so that people pay attention to me
because what what later develops in the
story is he's just a very lonely
desperate person and for good reason
like she nobody likes her but you can
tell why wouldn't this is this is who
she is and then there's the point where
she she put on the whole charity thing
but near her own husband and her
messages messages were weird as well so
that didn't come from the same town so
she puts on a charity baseball game
because he was a baseball fan and he
played for a team and the guy liked
messages her rings are up and he's like
messages out he's like why is the
baseball game your hometown well she's
like because it was my idea it's like
sorry he died yeah his family his
friends his baseball team all in his
town but you even after death still want
this to be about you and she was like
don't take credit for my idea
aha and it's like wow like even after
that the gravitas of the situation had
not Sun strain at all and in that
courtroom what else really nailed nailed
how selfish this person was and Wow
was she selfish was the only time she
cried was when they were sentencing her
yeah all of the pain all of the messages
all of the agony that she'd caused in a
big way no flicker of emotion just
deadpan and the second day of sentencing
her the waterworks come on and I thought
you unbel like this is unbelievable
this is why I talk about this because I
was like wow people like this or really
to be avoided so how much do you think
it is about mental health where it's
like she is clearly very mentally ill
she's my point does her mental state
explain and possibly take away from what
she didn't say I think that a lot in
court they declare mental illness
because it's an easy often it's like
when you don't when there isn't an
explanation for why someone could do
something so wicked and evil it's easy
to go I was insane and it's like were
you though like did you think you were
the second coming of Jesus were you that
insane appertaining act down no but
unless you literally think aliens are
coming to take you away in all of that
boy like if your whole behavioral
pattern suggests that you've completely
lost your mind
fair enough that's a defense but when
when everything else that you're doing
in your life you're getting good grades
you're graduating you're you're like
everything she's doing she's able she's
fully functioning she was also
psychologically analyzed by a
professional a lot not long after and
was shown to be more or less completely
fine she's immaculate mmm
she is drip like she is not serving her
to losing her [__] yeah she dressed very
well for court so a spy she's immaculate
she's very well-spoken we're not dealing
with her nutter here a nutter and a sick
evil [__] are not the same thing he
so Ted Bundy was not mentally ill Ted
Bundy is gorgeous Ted Bundy was an evil
clever man and this is what we're
dealing with here someone who can use
love and control and influence to
manipulate someone but she was almost to
a degree even slicker than than a Ted
Bundy the the level of evil where did
and especially from such a young age
like she's even almost more dangerous
because she was able she didn't even
have to get her hands dirty she was able
to get the victim that killed himself so
with everything wider than the court
case right and not specifically involved
with this situation how does it reflect
on society now that this person was
constructed and came together in this
age that we think we know we can we're
so first home this is the thing I think
this is the first time we've really
talked somewhat of the [__] plea but
we've had a transcript everything
basically said how many abusive
relationships around the world wear to
the shoe on the other foot in the man
for example is just telling the woman
what a piece of [__] [__] yourself yeah
every day he treats her like [__] he's
beaten arrow apiece paralyzed and all
the horrible things he can't and one day
he comes home and she's dead
but there's no record of it and there's
no proof of it this has probably been
going on in many different ways of many
different forms for a long long long
time it's just now because of the phone
we've got actual proof of it but what I
mean is how bad Lee does it reflect on
society that we've constructed someone
like this and that this person even
existed at this point because we know
the outside psychological influences
that pop culture that TV that you know
she was on medication that all these
things to cocktail of all this stuff she
wanted to be popular yeah I think that's
the cause of it that as well for her
yeah that's where that that's where it
begins
so how responsible how responsible
though is she for that side of it does
that make her evil that she
was this the all these circumstances
came together to make her this person is
she then responsible of that at such a
young age for being a young woman who's
clearly going through difficult things
herself how responsible issue for that
because there are other people out there
who would claim the other way where it's
almost like well this was she was she
was manipulated in her own way you know
she wasn't loved by a parent she had
this yet that all these different things
most everyone has outside fuckless the
fact that she's watching Glee and saying
Lea Michele become a martyr because she
survived her boyfriend's death doesn't
mean she should then want her boyfriend
who dies not sure he has the same glow
from it yeah but it is in assume what
you're saying I think the fact is though
because this is a one-off or it's a very
rare thing that happens proves that it
isn't something where we can go oh well
it's not her fault because there was
outside factors we're all dealing with
outside factors every single day how
many times you think it possibly happens
we're because suicide isn't the only bad
thing that can come from this there are
probably some relationships out there
where people are self farmers they're
probably thought eating disorders but
there are so many things that we had
list here I'd go into this there's men
out there calling the girlfriends fart
and a new girlfriend having issues
because of it and I sexual abuse this
body abuse is physical that there's
there's you know mental there's all
these different things it's probably
loads of relationships even even when
you know even when you've been in
relationships speaking from personal
experience where you get questioned
every [__] right what you doing what
you do why doing this yeah yeah control
that is that conduct in itself as is the
beginnings of something I mean it's a
level of abuse and that's partly it's
also very difficult to call out because
it's um it's the it's deniable there's
bill deniability there's a notion of arm
just wondering I was just wondering why
it doesn't feel like we're it's not only
it isn't feel that way it's also good
I've seen people like that where I've
known people who have been controlled in
a relationship and they've had it where
someone is message and where are you and
then that person and they've gone arm
just blah blah blah doing this and then
you I've turned to man gone
may that's [__] weird they text you
every 10 minutes you okay now you coming
home you doing this you doing that that
is that is the beginnings of stuff where
it could mean you're not already long
enough if you're not a strong human
being male or female cuz it happens on
both sides that [__] can get worse and
and if you don't stand up to those
people it can bring you further and
further down in the level of control
that they have just grows and grows and
grows and grows until people become a
shell of themselves and they begin to
control everything you see everything
you do the people you see you know I've
sporting the girls who before I've had
very controlling boyfriends who they're
like yeah I forgot who I was yeah and
then you're like really like this guy
used to be like that like what I mean I
don't know what people would think about
me is what I would be like but like I
think you should let someone just be
themselves I don't be like where are you
what you do you can't do this you got a
dress like that you got to eat this you
go like who has time to worry about and
what it the weird thing is the weird
thing is where it all stems from that
control and that power that they are
using the squeeze that other person down
and make them feel so small it's because
it all comes from the lack of self-worth
inside the person doing it the person
who feels insecure about who they are so
and that's where this girl destroyed
that boy is because she was insecure
self come explore that for a second
so I know there's a lot of people out
there don't like Jordan pizza anymore
because some people think he disappeared
down a right-wing wormhole or whatever I
happened to describe don't really care
what people say yeah I think his
literature is actually quite good I
think on a micro level he's better than
his macro but he does some really good
talks on breaking down Disney films and
I recently watched one channel it's so
funny
gone when I watch this [__] yeah I
thought [__] me Disney you've got a lot
that unsee yeah the first things I
thought that I had because it's like
this fairy tale that people are born
indoctrinated from day one it's like
Aladdin meets the [__] princess and
all happily ever and it's like this is
[__] like what
we need as a Disney movie where the the
guy meets the girl the girl falls in
love he's perfect she's perfect and then
he gets hit by a bus and then she's
gotta go and find another guy and she
ends up with a [__] and she's pretty
miserable but she always misses the
original guy that's a lot more like real
life so that's meet Joe Black
that's meet Joe Black where they meet in
a coffee shop and then the guy gets hit
by a bus but death has no really girl
it's gorgeous in apparently I've just
thought of it but you just thought yeah
I mean you think you have fabric goodbye
so Jordan Peterson lays out why Lion
King is so important for the path of
young men and why it's about the path
that most yeah so was I I love the line
right well then you'll love this so
obviously he loses his father big moment
for any young man losing a parent but
especially losing their dad and
realizing that that the fail ability of
that person that that person was tricked
all those kind of things and then also
relays realizing evil exists he runs
away from it and he goes away to
paradise with Timon and Pumbaa who are a
bit like those teenage friends that
maybe lead you away from having
responsibilities and all those kind of
things and then the crux of this talk is
about how very often a woman can in a in
a good way for some people but not for
everyone bring responsibility and a
constructive structure to a man that you
grow up by chat yet by challenging you
taking you away from those friends that
make you responsible or being like God
you know those friends needs to grow up
as well and challenging you and making
you into a man and reminding you of
responsibilities awesome truly yeah now
in that there's something really healthy
there and maybe that's only really the
role that someone that you love can play
or someone that you feel you're in an
intimate relationship with can play but
it's also how Olson doesn't explain the
way they blatantly shagged when they
offered another yeah although sex is
obviously that her face in that wish
where they're having sex
Jordan Peterson does pause it there and
laugh and he's like he's like it's a
lion but even I find it's a because her
eyes are so international sign for
letters yeah she's like less scary
though yeah
but at the same time what I found really
funny about that was how can everyone in
that room look at that and go they're
having sex that's so hilarious
until me can do yeah that was doesn't he
smashed it with that for that ruse well
he didn't smash it that was a very lucky
it was lovely but the point is that it
is very often that the responsibility in
a relationship on a woman are on a man
to help that other person mature is
really important but there are so many
people out there who haven't matured
themselves or are ready for a
relationship who won't help you mature
they will help human change to be the
person that they want you to be they
will be that manipulative person and the
amount of true people who have been
through that but the the controller has
made out as if they are the person who's
trying to help that's such a massive red
flag that most people can't identify
unfortunately too many people don't see
it coming and by the time they realize
it it's too late they're already a year
into the relationship and they're
friends one of their friends check Simon
goes who the [__] are you like what
happened you know me and some people
because of the fear of being lonely
don't have the strength to get off their
[__] arse and go I'm not gonna put up
with this anymore and I'm going
absolutely and it that requires a lot of
strength because being loving someone
and being in that relationship and the
security and the you know and the idea
of being alone again there's so many
factors that keep people in that box and
like [__] that box don't ever allow
yourself to be a man let's talk the
other way where there are many desperate
teenage girls out there and many
desperate teenage boys who want to have
a loving relationship who do feel lonely
who maybe sometimes will be so desperate
that they don't realize what they're
doing and then afterwards they realize
wow I've actually become a nasty person
I'm trying to manipulate someone else a
lot of that's don't new upbringing nor
and I get a lot of that is down to this
this insecurity it's don't do people not
being a whole person and this is a term
that gets thrown around that a lot of
people don't understand but when you
have the love of a parent or parents
and they make you they build you up
because that's what you're doing when
your parent in the child they and they
let you feel like you are good enough
you are enough you are anything you want
to be you can do it these things that
parents can make you feel that when you
do meet the right person you're not
searching for love or things that you
that you've never had before
you're searching for someone who loves
themself like you love yourself because
of the great upbringing you've had who
can then bring that love together yeah
and that doesn't happen a lot and when
you're a teenager let's view you in my
opinion you shouldn't be looking for a
[__] relationship when you're a
teenager because mentally you're not
ready for it yeah and that's not
patronizing that's not it's really that
you are in the process there's a real
there's a good reason why teenage
relationships don't last
there's also a good reason why you don't
take a cake out halfway through baking
yeah isn't taste good yet hey don't get
me wrong like I understand we you need
those first loves as well to actually
get into a position to be mentally ready
for the right person so that there is
there is a reason how they but they
never work let's be honest yeah so I
guess that that's the difficult side of
it is you don't want to pick someone out
to be your first love and sort of be in
the relationship like listen this isn't
gonna work because you're my first love
at the same time it's important that you
go through that they did like look I
know I've probably [__] up a lot of it
it is possible that you can pick the
first love and it can last it's just
[__] unlikely but what yeah I agree
apparently it's it's like getting a
hole-in-one on your first golf swing
like it's unlikely so apparently
although I am good apparently it takes
three relationships really and there are
three sort of formative relationships in
your life the first will be a very naive
one the second one will most possibly be
a very painful one and the third one
will most likely be something where
you've learned from the first two right
I'm saying this is a very common
narrative in series in theory right
can we flag that if you have been a
nasty abusive person in a relationship
and everyone at some point has done
something nasty in a relationship when
you break up people say nasty things
they'll say that you were the nasty
person in relationship
don't make your identity out of being
that person look at what you've done
there and in the same way as if you've
been hurt
work out that you're also hurting
yourself when you're an abusive person
in relationship because I know there
will be a lot of people who will have
watched that documentary and not related
to the guy but actually be a teenage
girl and relating to that girl or and
yeah and relating to that intensity
don't make your identity out of being
the bad guy you can change you can still
be a better person the person I was when
I had my first relationship is
unrecognizable - who are you exactly
yeah that's because and many
relationships after that I was I oh [__]
I need not do so like for example there
was things like if a girl had been with
the girl I was saying had been with a
boy who was better than me in any way
if I thought he was bad I would have a
problem with that I'll be like don't
[__] mention him to me ever again you
know what I mean like I'd be really
controlling Brian often says that about
I don't bolt wooden I [__]
but you know what I mean like there was
a I was threatened dancing I was
insecure
once again the insecure insecurity is
like the root of so many problems and
relationships and that was and I
remember how did it feel when II went
out I don't know I became extremely self
confident in Sal and my self-worth was
there but not in an arrogant way as much
as people might think I'm arrogant it
was like from I think even sexually I
was talking to a girl about sexual
experiences he'd had with a guy she'd
[__] the guy who had a bigger dick
than me and there was a there was a mark
I was like [__] 12 in like whatever
it was why I was like like Jesus
yeah but in my head I was like oh good
for you like it was right if there was a
there was a thing way which is all like
I don't I don't actually care anymore
about any of that and I was like because
I'm a man now I'm actually a man who's
actually a way that every girl that you
meet the likelihood is well the reality
is she will have been with a guy who
either makes more money than you mix I
laugh at other new makes a combat other
than you just something better than you
do the point is just trying to think of
what he did better than me the package
that I bring to the table
not literally yeah it is huge is unique
is is is something is something where
whether they do one thing but other me
the bottom line is I know that in
everything I bring this makes this
person happy and they make me happy and
and that's that's all that matters
anything and actually I'm interested in
knowing her life in their experience and
I don't want her to feel like she can't
[__] tell me about I had this kinky
sex before or we went on a great trip or
we I had memories with this / I don't
want to feel like they can't confide in
me do you know I was fine worried about
that you love that person now so the
people who have been before you have
helped to make that person the person
they are now but so why would you not
want to hear yeah but but this is the
thing is though I was an immature
writing testosterone-fueled insecure
young man right I'm not blaming you but
I and and there was a parade that was
hurt whenever any woman said anything
was bare butt about anything I'm talking
their car they drove the dresser
anything it used to set me off like I'd
be in a mood for the rest of that day
like don't [__] talk to me you know
mean yeah mmm and letting that go and
just being like really comfortable with
who I am it's amazing made me a better
person
it also makes you ten times more
attractive to me I don't mean to me yeah
well like yeah I've glutton or though
yeah let's have a little kiss I ever
skip the bus step but the point is it
does make you ten times more attractive
to a person when you can just be like
because you know what [__] it like I
that's true self contact that's not well
I'm not talking about faith cockiness
that all men have when they swagger into
a bar and they're looking for a woman to
[__] pull some man house I know I had
it but I'm just saying like real self
confidence is and that is that is part
of why when everyone was laughing at my
demons and all of that so I actually
could handle that because it's like yeah
[__] it
like that's just sex like it's not a big
deal and and I'm actually happy with who
I am as a person
yeah I mean don't get me wrong there's
things I'd like to work on but I know
I'm not I'm not a bad person at etc and
that is about growing up and it's
in me [__] 30 years to do that you
know what I mean and I long time and I
know some people who are [__] 50 and
60 who've never do that but it's about
like owning your shortcomings and
actually going yeah I'll work on that
and accepting what you really are and
you when you're a teenager you're males
of that because you don't even know who
you are yet you've got to get through
knowing finding out who you are dealing
with the fact that you're not going to
like some of what that is and then
accepting that and usually from 20 to 30
I feel like that's what that period is
20 to 25 is sort of finding out what it
is and 25 to 30 years accepting that and
if you're particularly smart you can
make it 30 to 50 52 and you'll go
further
yeah a lot of it I guess what I dislike
is not dislike but maybe find troubling
is when people go well I'm a man now
I've done the growing and very often
they regressed you know and I mean I was
the other deal saying about this and I
was like the people who are the the
dumbest or the ones what the minute you
think you know everything there is to
know or life is about to kick you in the
balls it's an actual psychological a
Contin of what the term is called but
it's an actual psychological issue right
because it's basically the if you are
done you will overestimate how good you
are because I'm not smart enough to work
out how dumb you are
absolutely and so it the best analogy
for that is when a lot of new editors or
cameramen come in and work with us a lot
of them think they've got it nailed and
they've worked out because they're still
at the beginning of their journey yeah
but the more you know the more likely
you are to think that you know very
little about a situation
so that's why when someone comes in
they're like yeah I pretty much know it
doubt that person more than you've ever
doubted anything because there's no way
that they know for real when you are in
when you're messaging someone sometimes
things can go a little bit intense and
in that moment you get caught up you
create this fantasy in your mind or
trailer yeah you create all these little
things which can either turn you on or
you'll be lustful towards part part of
me wondered how much of this
relationship was that
not our relationship with the
relationship on there this I felt that
this is what I was trying to say about
fantasy hey cookie it was I don't know
how to describe it
almost like suicide porn it was almost
like let's create this and do this whole
thing like it isn't really that there is
no romanticism in suicide there is no
glory there is no everlasting eternal
legacy there was just sadness and she
didn't understand what the [__] she was
getting into at all and neither did hear
Beth and how much of that and oli the
people who truly know other parents and
it's when he killed himself but I wonder
whether that bubble burst and she was
like [__] there's actually like real
consequences oh yeah because oh yeah and
that's where the tears came in because
she was a child crying for her freedom
and the fun the funny thing that they
did they pled not guilty they drugged it
out as long as they could they did
everything they could to make sure she
did no prison time and the irony of it
is if they pled guilty at the start they
probably would have gotten a pack of the
rest if they'd accepted jail time at the
start she would have went in a juvenile
prison but because they drug it out as
so long as they did and showed no class
in the disgraceful behavior that she'd
showed she had up in an adult prison for
15 months
well then part of that so look at the
lesson areas if she just held her hands
up she would've gotten less much less
than the way she'd drug it out the way
she did well then part of that then is
also that she was advised badly because
it was a [__] prick yeah I mean he
tried his best mate he was working
bellend yeah he was working with poor
tools I guess but yeah the part that is
it is the advice but one thing that
annoyed me was how good she looked on
the final day she got I was like she
looked at cara delevingne no but she had
like short hair she like I'm like you're
right you've got your life together she
looks like she's about to go like model
general roméo yeah although she can get
yeah she didn't look like she was
devastated and I don't know for me you
often say people who do really shitty
things look terrible
Tony Blair for example he looked awful
he looks evil now yeah the Green Goblin
because I mean in theory
eventually your conscience has to take
impact and in your face your body it
shows on the other you can say what you
want Tony Blair can see where you it
shows how racked with guilt of the
goddness how many people he's being
responsible for deaths with her it
doesn't show
she looks beautiful chin and I mean she
looks like there's nothing wrong with
her
yeah and I'm like that's the level of
guilt that she has none whatsoever maybe
because she never loved him yeah in my
opinion she never cared about him this
is her movie that she's living now and I
just wonder if she's realizing that in
the movie she's actually the bad guy
yeah I don't think she's working on you
yeah it depends me put the act that's
that is sad isn't it I think we're done
I'd say so as well I've been sitting out
other people think and especially
teenage girls who careful where you're
going with us in the comments in the
comments I'd be especially interested to
know what a teenage girl thought of this
because maybe from a teenage girl's
perspective they've just got another
view on it and I don't mean that in a in
a I think women a voltage because
they've all been two noses at one point
and even if I have your old personally I
read the comments every now and then and
I think everyone's going to be full and
disgusted enough be honest with you so
we'll see any 3sat is it both of those
people came to a sad end yeah don't
forget to hit that like button subscribe
thanks for watching and we'll see you
later I just like the matter